this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us america we're glad
you're here open phones this hour at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i'm solo today plus or minus a few
pounds of turkey left over from the week
earlier but uh we'll be hanging out
together you me and the turkey the phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five common sense for your
dollars and cents common sense that is
so rare that now having it in our
culture is like having a superpower
joseph is with us joseph is in dallas
texas hi joseph how are you
hey dave i'm doing very well
good what's up
i love the show i've been listening to
your podcast
for the last several months
wanted to ask your thoughts about making
the decision
uh
my wife and i i'm currently working uh
she's been a stay-at-home mom for the
last uh
five and a half years
and uh her former boss reached out to
her
to ask if she would be interested in
coming back to work
um and we have a two-year-old and a
five-year-old
and so the the boys are getting ready to
start preschool uh and kindergarten
and so the timing of it seems like it
might make sense but i was interested
what your thoughts were as far as
making the decision to go from staying
at home to uh you know to working
parents
yeah
well there's nothing wrong with it um
lots of working parents are great
parents
um it's not it doesn't require you stay
home to be a good mom
um but there's also nothing wrong with
deciding i want to stay home and spend
my time on my kids
so there's uh you know people get judged
for either one i can tell you that uh
but not here right
i'm going to support you either way
whatever you decide to do uh what i what
i wouldn't so so i'm not going to throw
a blanket on this and go oh well she
must go back to work or oh no she can't
go back to work i would never do that
that's not i think the question is how
much are they going to pay her
a lot more than me
how much
uh
115 000 okay pretty tempting then huh
uh yeah yeah attempting to hurt the
biggest
yes i mean we're both excited at the
opportunity we're baby step two right
now so we'd be able to become debt free
very quickly like by the end of next
year and the trade-off is what
what's the trade-off what's the loss
time with time with our kids uh having
to hire you know uh a nanny or daycare
uh to take care of them uh that's the
primary things
okay
well the two-year-old from two to five
you're never gonna go get those years
back uh but there's certainly nothing
wrong with
uh again having daycare having a nanny
uh having after-school care whatever the
process is people do it every day and uh
it's it's not immoral it's not wrong
you're not a bad parent um
but you've just got to decide okay what
kind of boundaries can i put on this i
mean this guy's wanting to work 40 hours
not 80 right
yes correct that's a boundary number one
uh then
i don't know maybe there's some
flexibility around
school time about when she shows up or
when she doesn't show up at the office
right
yeah
especially now
their
work from home i think 50 percent of the
time so well that's a big deal she's
going to be at home 50 of the time
correct oh wow okay so she we're only
talking about
two and a half days or two days a week a
problem then right
right
uh
who watches the kid while at home while
she's working
nanny
yeah we we don't know that yet we just
have to find somebody well i think what
you've got if sharon and i are doing
this decision we have to put down
exactly how this is going to go down and
then look at that and say we're trading
that for 115 000 bucks
that's a trade
is it a good trade and if it's a good
trade we'll do the trade um
you know and lots of people look up and
they go the trade is not worth it um my
wife desperately wants to be at home
full-time with the kids and not work and
there's not really any amount of money
that is you can put on the other side of
that scale that makes it tip and so then
they choose to stay home and there's
nothing wrong with that and there's
nothing wrong with going dadgum this is
quite honoring an old boss from five
years ago calls up and offers us the
brinks truck let's this is on that's
honoring to her it says a lot about who
she is right
absolutely which is that that's a nice
compliment it makes it really tempting
as well because they obviously have huge
respect for her so
good stuff good stuff um there's not a
right or wrong answer brother but i
would get down and say this is our life
is currently x
if we do this exactly what does our life
look like change
exactly what are we going to do exactly
how we're going to handle it
then you know the trade you're making
because you're trading 115 000
for whatever stress or absenteeism or
time away from the kids you're putting
on the table and if it's minimal away
from the kids
you know it's really tempting to look at
really tempting
marx with us in new york city hey mark
welcome to the ramsey show what's up in
your world
hey dave thank you for having me on the
show sure he'll make it very simple uh
over the past few years i've made some
poor financial decisions and i've ended
up in 150 000 of credit card debt good
lord what'd you buy
i didn't buy i didn't buy anything i um
i was going through a phase drug
addiction and things file that spiraled
out of control i had a very you know i i
was very good with money in in
in a past life and i had a high credit
score and i blew through everything
now the reason that happened to me was
because my father died a tragic death
and i uh i went through a lawsuit which
recently settled so
i just don't know how to get my life
back in order
i am employed gainfully employed
however it's just so overwhelming what
do you mean
uh just under 200.
cool how long have you been driving
what's that how long you been driving
what three years three years what was it
uh prescription painkillers okay how old
are you i was
i'm gonna turn 31. okay
i'm sorry about your dad how long ago
did he pass
uh october 2017.
obviously your hero
no well yeah of course i mean
well i mean if it was devastating to you
he meant god to you yeah
um
what other uh what other family and
friends and support have you got around
you while you're walking out your
sobriety
uh i mean
everyone is behind me um
i mean it's like really a thing of the
past i mean i'm so blessed i mean
i mean you got good
support know what
i good support i i didn't know the
dangers you know i was i was uh getting
some surgery during the time i saw how
they died and
i mean you it just snaps you become
dependent on these things oh yeah
they're good to you i mean
it's embarrassing to even say i mean uh
goodness i mean oh when you're hurting
and you're not hurting anymore they're
good to you and it just it compounds i
know i've heard about it
all right i'll tell you what i think you
got the chemistry to make it uh you just
need a game plan that's going to give
you a little bit of hope can you hang on
with me through the break and let's work
on that
absolutely you got all the components to
win this dude i think you can win it and
i think i can show you how we'll work on
it together in a minute hang with me
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
getting out of debt is smart saving and
investing is smart but there's one key
to winning with money that people
overlook all the time and that's
protecting your finances from
emergencies and this is where insurance
comes into play there are 10 kinds of
insurance coverage that you probably
might need based on depending on where
you are in your life and what it looks
like today and we've built a tool called
the coverage checkup to show you which
types you need to add drop or adjust and
we'll even rank your coverage list by
importance we'll email it to you and
connect you with a ramsey trusted
insurance provider so you can get your
plan in place fast and with the cheapest
possible price seriously this could be
the most important five minutes you
spend today donald h wrote in and said i
like how and i like how he put it he
said for anyone who has not completed
this checkup do it right now you never
know when something will happen and you
never want to leave your family in a bad
situation go to ramsey solutions dot com
slash checkup don't let an emergency
sneak up on you protect your family's
future ramsey solutions dot com slash
checkup it's completely free all right
we're talking with mark in new york city
makes 200 000 years got 150 000 in
credit card debt ran it up during uh
three years ago he's been drive for
three years off of his prescription drug
addiction uh which occurred after the
loss of his dad tragically he's in his
30s and wanting to know if he's bankrupt
is that a fair summary of what you told
me so far sir
uh yes there's one other x factor uh
because you know with my dad's situation
i recently settled a lawsuit
so now i have a
a settlement and uh
i just don't know how to
best use this as a tool to repair what
i've done
okay and how much is the settlement
i i really want to say in the air but
seven figures
over a million
yeah okay all right cool when you and
your debt's 150 000
yeah okay well obviously you're not
bankrupt obviously you're not bankrupt
no no sir i'm i'm
very blessed okay all right so um
uh i misunderstood the the question then
okay because you can't file bankruptcy
the judge would just take some of your
money and pay your bills it wouldn't and
laugh at you you know he wouldn't do it
so um
so the 150 000 uh is it all current or
are you behind on it or what no
no i haven't i haven't even looked at it
in in three years i mean
part of those three years i was kind of
out of commission yeah so the 150 000
figure comes from the last time you
looked at it or recently you just called
all of them and got the new numbers
uh
that's the last time i looked at it i i
don't even know where the debt is or who
bought it or or
where where it is in the debt
yeah all right but you have an idea
where it started
yeah how many different how many
different credit cards
about five
okay
all right
uh are you doing uh
uh
uh
anonymous are you doing 12 step
no no no it's uh i i listen i went down
that road and that was part of that
three years thing um
i i just
you know i grew up catholic i just
returned to
my faith in christ and and what's
important to me
but as far as spending my life in a uh
special right now i wasn't asking you to
do that i was just ask trying to get
context to where your head is
because because 12 steppers have a
framework in which they look at things
and that's i was trying to see if that's
what you were doing that's okay no
problem i'm not trying to sell you on
twitter i think it's great for some
people it's just it's not for me okay
that's fine you're dry i'm going with
dry okay
that's a big thing you stay sober i'm
not arguing with you um the uh
money in heart yeah so what you've got
to do is you have some hard work to do
you've got a business to run here and
your business is
uh i'm gonna let's just pretend i'm not
going to but let's pretend i hired you
for a hundred thousand dollars a year as
a part-time job in addition to your
regular job and your job for a hundred
thousand dollars a year is go back and
clean up this guy's mess named mark and
your job how would you do that you would
go back to the last source of anything
you had and you would figure out okay
the you know i borrowed twelve thousand
dollars from citibank and then i contact
citibank and they've added on 73 million
fees and now it's 22 000 so i've got two
figures i got a 12 and i got a 22. okay
and then i do the same thing with uh jp
morgan i do the same thing with whoever
wherever you got the stinking cards okay
and you go back and you try to source
them they've probably sold them now
here's what i want you to understand
if they have sold them to a debt buyer
which they likely have if it's three
year old debt
a debt buyer will buy that money
approximately a nickel on the dollar
and so they're going to buy
a 1 000 credit card debt for 50 bucks
got it
got it and you are then then they dump
you into a phone room
a boiler room 9 000 people in cubicles
with fluorescent lights calling people
all day long trying to get money out of
them and couldn't get a better job so
they've got a really bad job called
credit card collector it sucks as a job
and they don't last very long on the job
and they lie and they yell and they do
anything they can do to get money out of
you and so that's who you're dealing
with on the other end pretty much scum
of the earth
okay understood and so your job then is
to say okay you paid a nickel on the
dollar you're trying to get two dollars
for every dollar that was owed we're not
going to do that i will pay you today
what the original balance was as
settlement in full
and you can do that easily you have
plenty of money
and you get it in writing from them they
will do that deal all day long they'll
probably take a quarter on the dollar
but you're probably going to argue with
them a lot more and you have the money
to pay your bill so you legitimately
borrowed twelve thousand dollars you've
got over a million you can pay the guy
twelve thousand dollars okay so you pay
them twelve thousand bucks it's what you
owe
and so but you don't pay them 22 000
because that's what they're going to try
to stick you with is all the stuff they
do
go ahead forgive me let me ask you
should i use a debt consolidation no or
should i hire an attorney no you should
go do this do this myself yeah she'll
give me the best deal personally yes
well it's a hassle i gave you a new job
it's amazing i understand well let me
tell you that consolidation doesn't work
at all they're just going to throw the
thing in another pile and create another
mess for you that's another scam group
and an attorney by the time you finish
paying them you're going to wish you'd
done it yourself and they are not going
to be as efficient as you're going to be
it's your new hobby how many different
accounts do you think there is
open for debt probably five
only five
you borrow 30 000 bucks a piece on these
things
yeah oh well this is a lot easier than i
thought then
you have to do five deals by phone come
on man
all right i i just don't even know who
to call well the last person that had
the account
and they'll tell you it's good they just
call them we sold it also
yeah who you know i'm calling about this
account we sold it who just sell it to i
need to get in touch with them i need to
settle it and also pull up a copy of
your credit bureau report it'll pop up
on there maybe who owns it because
they're probably dinging you like crazy
trying to get the money out of you there
definitely but you need to correlate and
so here's the thing okay
do not pay more than the original
principal balance you don't morally owe
more than that they're going to come
after you for a lot more than that
if you want to argue for a little less
you're welcome to but you've got the
money i wouldn't i would just pay what i
owe it's only 150 000 bucks after all
said and done here okay the third thing
is always get it in writing they get no
money unless you have in writing
before you send money in writing exactly
what the amount is and the last thing is
under no circumstances do you give them
electronic access to your checking
account
because they lie and they will take the
22 000 out after you settle them with
them for twelve thousand
and try getting it back then yeah that's
a pain in the butt okay
email is fine i want it in writing and
you can either take a prepaid debit card
for each one of these or thirty grand a
piece approximately um or you can have a
separate checking account that just has
that money in it only but do not allow
them access to multiple dollars beyond
what you are settling with them for in
writing
five different people you gotta track
down and do deals with and this is your
penance
this is you paying back you know this is
you working through and cleaning up the
mess that you made
and it's not that hard actually you can
do it
and and i'm proud of you for attempting
it and if you need some help as you're
working through it you call me back
anytime in writing no electronic access
to your checking account don't give them
any more than was originally owed when
this all started
[Applause]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage walter is with us hey
walter how are you better than i deserve
dave i love it good answer man where do
you live uh in fayette missouri okay
what's fayette near um
not really anything
it's like right between kansas city and
st louis like you know throw dart you'll
find it got it okay very cool very cool
well welcome to nashville and you're
here to do a debt-free scream how much
have you paid off about 26 392 i think
okay very good how long did this take uh
31 months 31 months and your range of
income during that time i went from 28
000 a year to 38 000. good for you what
do you do for a living um now i'm a
probation officer okay all right and you
paid off almost a thousand dollars a
month making about 30 grand that's
pretty impressive
i mean you're working extra doing some
side gigs or what oh no i just but god
blessed me this whole time uh the first
first job i had uh worked through it
eventually had to leave it went to
another job this was all during 2020 by
the way worst time possible uh and then
went from the one job to my probation
job and all within the same year had to
move in the meantime had to buy a new
car oh wow um 2020 was a fun year as we
all know not yeah okay yeah well good
for you man so what kind of debt was
this 26 000 uh all student loans okay
yeah all right very cool good for you so
what's your degree in uh sociology all
right good well probation officer makes
sense then yeah yeah again i've been
blessed to have all jobs in the field
that i actually studied in so it's just
been crazy yeah good so what woke you up
two and a half years ago because that's
before the pandemic really right well
okay so this actually goes back a long
time my family's been listening to you
since we lived on the east coast this
was
fifth almost 20 years ago basically um
they were listening to you and i wasn't
listening to them uh at gang out of high
school i decided to be rebellious or
stupid depending on your point of view
and uh got into student loan debt didn't
work through college and then i was just
like oh i have a lot of debt um
i got to get this fixed so my dad my dad
mom they taught financial peace for the
church and they as a college gift they
brought me through it went through
financial peace and i was just like all
right laser intense
working the job just paying every single
extra cent i could towards the student
loans
okay so you just came straight out of
college and did this yeah okay how old
are you uh 25. okay awesome very good
all right well that's a good way to do
it a financial piece baby then yep
absolutely good good that's cool man
well mom and dad got to be proud then
yeah dad's actually right next to me
here in the studio so yeah
we're taking we took a trip down here i
actually had an email uh folder in my
gmail account that said trip to ramsey
solutions every time i paid off a loan
through that email in that folder so i
was able to look back and see okay it's
going down it's going down so yeah i
like it this was a goal the whole time
very good so they were cheering you on
for sure oh absolutely they they're
they're my my best coaches
very good okay so your mom and dad teach
fpu you've been through fpu and you've
paid off 30 26 000 in 31 months all of
this makes you an expert now uh uh so no
i mean because listen let me just tell
you there's a lot of people with
opinions that haven't done squat right
and you've actually done it yes you did
pay off the debt you're a hero now so
you're a guy who really did it really
making about 30k you really paid off a
thousand dollars a month roughly and uh
that really is beans and rice what do
you tell people the key to getting out
of that is um
there there's a couple keys one the
dollar store is your best friend um but
otherwise for me personally it was my
faith just believing okay god i know
this job's rough i'm gonna have to
change soon i'm gonna trust you with
this interview with whatever happens if
it works it works if it doesn't it
doesn't and god absolutely blessed me
and i interviewed a job they offered me
the job it was
crazy just how how much it worked for
towards his glory and a ten thousand
dollar raise oh yeah oh yeah that's nice
oh yeah well and fun fact actually from
the first job to the second job i
actually took a pay cut
it was closer to where i was living but
it was still a pretty decent cut and
then i went to the probation job which
then was 10 000 overall yeah ah okay all
right so a little side kick okay yeah
good good for you man well done very
well done
so what was the hardest part of this
whole thing um
hardest part i mean not going out with
friends all the time that was pretty
hard and actually from work i have um so
i got booked with your financial piece
um it was the total guide to money i
think i believe it was
and i would bring that to my training
with me and during lunch i wouldn't go
out to lunch i'd sit there and be
reading your book just pouring through
it and i'd have co-workers come in just
be like what are you doing there i'm
like well i'm trying to get debt free
and gain wealth and they're like oh
you're gonna be a scrooge when you grow
up i'm like no i'm going to be giving
away a lot of money once i get rich i'm
just getting out of debt first then they
kept saying like oh well everyone has
debt i'm like well i don't want to be
like everyone i want to be you know
strive for a little bit higher than just
average yeah so that was that was still
hard just hearing that constant you know
hey you can't do this you can't do this
type of thing
it requires not giving a rip what other
people think to go win at almost
anything in our culture because there's
always some idiot with an opinion right
i mean they're everywhere and so it's
just uh it's amazing well
congratulations thank you i'm so very
proud of you how's it feel to be free oh
it was amazing i sent out that last uh
the last check back in july i sent a
text to my group of friends we do a
bible study together i'm just like hey i
just sent sally mae the eviction notice
and my buddy says wait does that mean
you're debt-free i'm like as soon as
this check clears i am absolutely
debt-free so
very cool very cool good for you
so when you started this
you're fresh out of college you got 28
000 income you got a 26 000 debt
you're standing at the base of mount
everest yeah and you got to climb this
freaking big hill it's intimidating it's
overwhelming right yeah oh yeah what was
easier
than you thought it was going to be when
you were standing at the bottom looking
up
um
i mean just honestly then this is a kind
of a weird thing but just sending the
checks was a lot easier than i thought
it would be um after going through
financial piece i'm i've been using your
every dollar app ever since i went
through financial peace and just being
able to go okay i only have this much
for food this much for entertainment
this much for all this stuff oh i can
send that much all right cool let's
write that check send it in the mail
forgot about it it just it was that was
so much easier than i thought because
you know i'm like man that's my money i
don't want to let it go but it was it
was easy yeah well it's gamified i mean
you see yourself getting traction right
and uh i mean a budget is gamification
of wealth building is really what it is
it shows you progress shows you traction
towards what you're getting to win and
you were really doing it no and a fun
thing i did um i bought a bunch of just
envelopes at walmart like the security
envelopes and i taped a little um
notepad piece of paper on there and i
just wrote tickets to freedom i had them
pre-printed for the student loan company
so all i had to do was slap a stamp on
there throw the check in pop it in the
mail and i printed way more of those
envelopes than i needed because i got
done a lot faster than i was even
guessing so
yeah i still have a bunch of those at my
house i'm going to be sending up a nice
little bonfire when i get back from yeah
they'll make good kindling oh that'll
make good kindling that'll you light the
fire with those puppies we're done we're
free absolutely for free so what are you
gonna do now um right now i'm focusing
on baby step three um just decided to
take this little vacation down here with
my dad uh we're just seeing the sights
going around having some fun gonna get
baby step three done and then have go
move forward and just
kind of see what got where god takes me
because he's been taking me a little bit
of everywhere over the past uh couple
years so it's like his will be done you
know amen amen well you're you're free
to do that now yes i am one master to
serve not to exactly good for you well
done well done well we've got a copy of
baby steps millionaires for you it comes
out january 11th but you're gonna get
one of the early release
copies uh for just for you because
that's the next chapter of your story go
on and become
outrageously wealthy so that you're
outrageously generous just like you were
telling those folks in the break room
that's exactly how it works we'll give
you a copy of the total money makeover
maybe one of those guys in the break
room will chew on it for a little while
i hope so we can hand it to them as a
pay it forward and maybe they'll be up
here before we know it just standing and
doing their debt debt-free scream
because that's what we want for folks to
be able to win well congratulations sir
thank you i'm proud of you you're a hero
well done
walter from missouri is 26 000 paid off
in 31 months making 28 to 38 count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream all
right lord jesus thank you for getting
me here to this point by your grace
alone i'm debt-free
[Applause]
that'll do
that'll do
yeah that's exactly how it works
now if uh
if you want to know why i come down here
every day still when i haven't had to
work for years it's because i get to
meet people like walter
he's incredible
look at that man that's pretty cool
right there
very very well done
and some of you are wondering if you
could do it
a young man just did that on 30 000
bucks a year please shut up
and park your ambulance and get your
butt in gear i mean walter if walter
didn't just throw you under the shame
bus nobody did get your butt in gear
people let's go
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
blinds.com gives us our question of the
day they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee that means even if you mess up
[Music]
and sometimes you do mess up because
sometimes i mess up on these things like
you miss measure
or this one i do all the time pick the
wrong color because i'm like
horrible at that stuff good at math not
good at aesthetics right well if you
mess up they'll make your blinds over
for free their 100 satisfaction
guarantee means even if you screw up
they cover you you get free samples free
shipping and new promos all the time
i always use the promo code ramsey to
get the best possible deal dawson is in
virginia i'm a 19 year old college
student currently in my junior year was
wondering if i should invest in and
build an airbnb business with my brother
the only debt i have is three thousand
dollars in student loans i have thirty
thousand dollars in stocks and eight
thousand dollars in savings we have a
lot of knowledge in this business
because my brother already owns one
uh we plan on paying cash for it
and i'd save until i had the amount for
my half would it be a good idea to go in
50 50 with my brother on a property it
would cost 110k
um
if you're debt free and you have an
emergency fund in place and you pay cash
for it
it's fine
the downside is this
uh there's several downsides um
beware of anything
when you've done it once and you call
yourself an expert
uh your brother has one of these and
airbnb
if airbnb is the only way the property
purchase makes sense don't buy it
it needs to also make sense in a
traditional rental if airbnb goes away
because there's a lot of municipalities
coming down on them and shutting them
down in different areas there's a lot of
problems with it the other thing is that
this is the highest hassle
highest possible hassle
rental that you can have
you're basically running a freaking
hotel
and it's a lot of work
and a lot of problems
and so the numbers that you see this
thing making on the stage
um i mean on on the page on the pro
forma of this
uh are not going to happen
it's going to be less than that and you
have not really anticipated the level of
work and if you let this stupid property
distract you from getting your degree
then don't do it at all
the second downside
other than that in this
situation is that you are now in a
partnership with your brother you are
single i don't know if he is
um and it may work well for a few years
and then you may need to sell out of it
uh because it's probably not something
you're going to own together when you're
80.
and so you need a detailed
written
partnership agreement that states what
happens
to this property or what happens in the
event one of you wants out
in the event that
one of you can't pay for their half or
don't can't do their part of their half
of the work
or the bills
uh in the event that one of you goes
down the toilet and becomes a drug
addict
or becomes disabled
or dies
or gets divorced and now you end up
owning a airbnb with his ex-wife
because the judge awards her his half
yeah that sounds like fun
not
these are the unanticipated things that
happen when you go into a partnership
even with your own brother
and so i'm not a big fan of that my
preference would be that you save up
your own money and you go by your own
after you get out of college
and you pay cash for it
uh it sounds like you've got the ability
to put some money together and that's
probably the direction i would go
also you said you had um
uh uh let me get my numbers right here
you have three thousand dollars in debt
thirty thousand in stocks and eight
thousand dollars in savings you should
write a check today and pay off your
debt
there's no reason for you to carry that
debt with that much money sitting around
so let's pile up the rest of the cash
make sure you graduate from college and
pay cash for your own airbnb would be my
preference that's what i would rather
you do
um rather than jumping ahead here
it this just all the glitters is not
gold
and this there's a lot more to this and
a lot more work than i i sense that you
realize may be wrong that's my sense on
it holly is with us holly is in
charleston west virginia hi holly how
are you
i'm great how are you better than i
deserve what's up
all right so i made my husband watch
borrowed future about a month ago and
he's finally on board with paying off
our student loans together we have about
350 000. good lord who's the doctor or
lawyer
we're both physician assistants yeah
okay well that's good you're both pa so
what do you what's your household income
about 200. good good okay and today's
actually his birthday he turned 42 today
yeah he's kind of concerned that he
doesn't have any retirement
at all he should be yeah yeah so he's
wanting to put some away for that i was
just wondering
no you're broke
yeah you're 350 thousand dollars in debt
right right you're talking about being
an investor you're broke
yeah
and i've got about 30 000 in my
retirement so do i need to put that on
hold and just through yeah
with everything you put your life on
hold
you don't need to go on vacation or go
out to eat you don't need to eat
anything but beans and rice
you need to live off of coupons and stay
at home and play board games and work
all the time as much hours as you can
get and you need to pay this off in
three years
all right three years when you're 45 i
want you to call me and tell me you're
debt free
all right well thank you so much can you
do that
i think we can he's uh he's working two
jobs i can work extra and we've been
doing the every dollar budget for about
a month and we've already paid off 3
500. so i think we're right on track i
just wasn't sure what to do no you're
not on track no no no i'm sorry you're
not on track you need to pay off 8 000 a
month
oh okay
you make thousand dollars a year
yep
okay a hundred thousand dollars a year
for three years and you're done
yeah we've got four kids and a child
support too so there's some other
payments in there but
uh we can definitely save more than we
have been yeah stop all your retirement
temporarily
stop all spending temporarily
and attack this like your house is on
fire the faster you get out the more
likely you are to get out and the more
wealthy you'll build for retirement
all right that's what i needed to hear
thank you so much
thank you
this is the ramsey show she's not gonna
do that open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five but
we'll do some form of it and hopefully
we'll get it dialed in and get there
yeah how fast can i get off the phone
with dave because it's making me really
nervous
justin's in charlotte north carolina hi
justin how are you
hey dave thanks for taking my call
sure man what's up
so i'm a college football coach
and my wife and i have been on fire
uh on your program since 2018 we paid
off a hundred thousand dollars worth of
debt good for you
we've got our emergency fund and now
we're on baby step four five six
uh my question is our goal we're in our
mid thirties 33 and 34 and our goal is
to be baby step millionaires by the time
we're 45. good and we know from your
teaching that you know
homeownership is going to be a big part
of your first million dollars of net
worth
and
the the reason i told you that i'm a
football coach is because you may know
or you may not know that
you know we move around a lot and you
know i've been coaching for about 13
years and
uh the longest i've stayed anywhere is
three years
so
knowing that information we've been
struggling you know we've followed your
plan to a t but we've been struggling on
on how do we navigate babysit six
how do we you know we want to buy a home
we want to own a home we want to pay it
off quickly
you know what should we do is the
question
do we keep running the rest of our
career i've got about 30 plus years left
in coaching or do we do we buy a home
and try to pay it off quickly i'd buy it
home and pay it off quickly and i would
sell it when you get ready to move
um
because you never know when you end up
landing the place where you'd stay a
while uh it's not always it's not like
the military we know in the military
you're gonna move every two to three
years we know that but we don't know
that with you it's just a matter whether
the regime changes or not and you go
with them or you go to a different job
and some of that you have control over
some of it you don't
but i would buy
because you're probably buying in good
metro areas too so i'm just going to buy
and get it paid off as fast as i can
sell it when you move
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone browse by topic or even
sync clips to your friends
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us america open phones
this hour as we talk about your life and
your money the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five pru is with us in orlando
hi pru how are you
hi danny thanks so much for taking my
call how are you better than i deserve
what's up
um so my husband and i um have been
trying to
work on their will
but we have a discord agreement on who
would be getting our assets
if both of us passed away
we don't have any children
if i follow the legacy journey principle
which i deeply believe in
it will break my
husband's heart
but if we don't then i have to work
through my resentment towards his family
so could you give me advice as if you
were my father
okay i'm a little bit uh confused what
you mean by the legacy journey principle
you have no children and you're saying
that i said or the legacy journey said
to do what with the money
um i believe that the the assets or the
money should be given to the people who
deserve it
um so it's regardless of whether you are
uh
those people are related to you or not
um so let's say if you were to have kids
and they
don't deserve it you don't give it to
them or if you have family member who
are
entitled yeah i probably would use a
different word if i can i don't use the
word deserve
um i use the word that i'm the manager
of the money for god
and i'm not gonna leave it to someone
who's gonna misbehave with the money
because it's part of my job as the
manager to make sure that another good
manager gets the money that's different
than deserve i'm not sure any of us
deserve that's why i'm better than i
deserve so i'm not sure we deserve
anything but
um but the um
but but you know who's going to do a
good job with us so he wants to leave it
to his family
and i take it you feel like they
misbehave with money
um
i wouldn't
be misbehaved but i
felt like
i i do see um why we have a disagreement
now because i don't think they misbehave
with money i think they um
they they don't want to spend so um they
don't um they're not generous
but they're not you know
grateful of course that his sister is
not grateful or generous but
i think um
she is a money saver
okay well so she's she's partially good
with money she's good at saving but not
good at giving
okay so um
and uh
and obviously you guys you know you you
don't really uh
enjoy her company you don't like her
much
yes um
she'd say things like whenever you are
with a woman meaning me you forget about
family
but they had a fight you know and then
she never called him or texted me when
my dad passed away
and then but then she blamed him for
for that and
and she criticized that i don't catch
her daughter but i mean
i don't think i'm responsible for
texting her daughter i i you know her
daughter's birthday gift you know every
year or
sometime we skip it but
okay so do you do you have family that
could be in the equation
i do have family
would you leave them any money
i would but
that's because they um we have different
value though we
they had they have helped us through
sick and sins
so my husband and i don't agree that um
you know we would like some of the money
going for them
you do both you do both agree that some
of the money goes to them
right and the only disagreement is he
wants to give some to his sister and you
and his sister don't get along
well actually um
he doesn't think that she needs it but
and she said that um
that money should go to her um kit
because her kid is
innocent which i would agree a hundred
percent if his niece was totally
grateful and generous you know giving
but
how much money are we talking about
well i feel like this is something uh
right now it's not that much it's maybe
like two or a thousand dollars because
we're still working toward you know
paying off the mortgage
um but that wasn't something that would
go on in the long run then our asset
would accumulate
yeah
okay
well i i tell you what i could do um i
mean sharon and i have a rule on this
kind of stuff whether it's on giving or
spending
or disagreements of this sort
when when we cannot come to resolution
we choose to do nothing
and so um in terms of leaving money to
his sister or his sister's kid
right now we're in disagreement because
you don't agree with the way they live
and the way that the relationship
towards you has been and he feels some
kind of a blood
need
based on blood only not based on
relationship to leave her money um right
and so um
what you probably need to ask yourself
is under what circumstances would you
feel good about leaving your niece or
nephew the money because it's not really
the sister and it might be
that we leave it into trust
for that person and when they meet those
circumstances it is released to them
uh for instance i'll just make up
something that i've seen people do okay
this child uh needs to agree to
give x number of dollars
uh or x percentage of the trust away
when the trust is released to prove
their generosity
uh this child needs to be
25 years old or whatever number you make
up okay
some people would say something like
they need to go through financial peace
university
they need to learn how to handle money
and handle money the way we teach and uh
so that we're in agreement with that um
and so on
so uh
uh
it is not a reward for being nice to me
though
that that part i don't agree with you on
uh the little nicky knacky stuff i text
somebody somebody didn't text me or
didn't call when my father died or
whatever that's not what this is about
this is about you were given this amount
of money to manage and you're gonna
leave it to someone else who also
manages it
the way you would want it managed for
good
and in my case as a christian they're
going to manage it god's ways
and so i'm not leaving money to someone
that's not walking with god in my case
and so that's consistent with our estate
plan and with our kids our kids can
disqualify themselves
from our will by
not choosing to manage money or live
their lives that way and they get to
choose that they're adults i can't tell
them what to do but then the result is i
can't leave money to you if you're a
heroin addict because you'll buy more
heroin
that would be dumb that would not be an
act of love
and because here's what happens when you
leave people money when anybody gets
money period here's what happens it
magnifies who you already are
[Music]
you're a jerk and you get money you
become a colossal jerk
you're kind and compassionate and
generous you get money you become
unbelievably outrageously generous
you become more of what you are
magnifies
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
if you're tired of living paycheck to
paycheck you don't have to live like
that anymore and you shouldn't have to
no matter how you've managed money in
the past or how much debt you have you
can take control of your money you need
the right plan financial peace
university will teach you that plan it's
the step-by-step class that's helped
almost 10 million people take control of
their money and feel in control of their
lives
you learn how to make a budget that
actually works get out of debt
spend and save wisely invest
wisely
become outrageously generous in fact the
average family pays off 5 300 in debt
and saves 2 700 in the first 90 days of
the class
we'll give you the plan but it's up to
you to get started
you can decide today
that you're done feeling stressed and
you're ready to take control by the way
it's up to you
financial peace university is available
in a ramsey plus membership that's how
you get started it includes the every
dollar app the premium version that
attaches to your bank
it's all the package it's the whole
thing you need to get your life
straightened out and become wealthy
ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu
that's where you find it financial peace
university
for decades
we've been showing people how to become
wealthy
as a result of getting out of debt
ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu
all right daniel is with us in vancouver
washington hi daniel how are you
hi dave i'm good thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
uh so my question is
we are currently debt free and we are
thinking about the college fund we have
a 21 month old boy
and uh
we have an investment property and we
were thinking to use that investment
property for the same reason as the
college fund so
we just keep it and whenever uh
like in 18 years or whatever when when
the boy's ready to go to college we just
sell it and we use that money
to fund whatever education he wants
i'm not sure if in like 17 18 years
colleges will still be a thing um i'm a
software engineer i'm working
as a software engineer without using my
degree in college like i i started like
like online stuff to to get that job so
i'm not sure if college fund
is still the way to go
well it's certainly okay to have an
investment for higher education um
i think knowledge will always be a thing
uh now the you know does it have to have
ivy on the side of a brick wall and be a
four-year degree
in uh german polka history uh no i think
that's already not a thing
but but can you get a degree in
something that is actually applicable
and valuable uh in the future oh i think
that'll always be a thing knowledge is
always valuable and i don't think that
currency is going to change the delivery
mechanisms
are going to look differently
higher education has stepped in the poo
and uh by continually raising the prices
and participating in this disastrous
epic student loan debacle that we have
in america and um you know so i don't
disagree with your summation or your
your general conclusion that things are
going to change is it going to go
completely away and there's not going to
be a need to educate your kid no your
kid's going to need to be educated in
some form or fashion
i don't know what that's going to look
like in 20 years and i'm with you i
suspect it'll be somewhat different but
i don't think all colleges and
universities and four-year degrees are
going to evaporate in the next 20 years
i don't think that's going to happen but
i think the market is going to force
them to correct themselves and become
affordable and relevant
and they've made themselves irrelevant
with the study of east
czechoslovakian medieval art as a degree
you know and bullcrap like that and this
is just ridiculous and people are
spending money big money to get degrees
that are absolutely guaranteed to make
you a barista at starbucks and that's
all they're worth so yeah that they've
made themselves irrelevant they've made
themselves
uber expensive but does that mean we
throw the baby out with the bath water
absolutely not education is important so
if you want to buy a rental house and
keep it 20 years to fund your kids
education whatever form that takes fine
with me
no problem with that no problem if you
did it with a 529 either by the way
either one's okay with me good question
hey guys if you have not seen
the most watched now documentary over a
hundred thousand people have viewed it
about student loans in america today
it's called borrowed future it's ours it
was produced by ramsey networks
and the ramsey production team did a
world-class job building this
documentary it is on
uh
amazon prime on apple tv
uh you can get it
at borrowedfuture.com
and get on google play
and you can rent it you know it's gotten
cold in a lot of your areas now people
watching tv a little more at night it's
getting dark earlier you're watching tv
a little bit more at night hey flip over
and watch something that actually will
teach you something and you'll learn
something you got kiddos you need to
watch borrowed future
hey you know and if you're a teacher and
you want to show borrowed future to your
classroom
we will let you do that free just get in
touch with us at borrowed future dot com
hundreds and hundreds of teachers have
already shown it in classrooms all over
america we are totally causing a holy
ruckus with this thing because we are
calling out
the out-of-control student loan industry
and how predatory it is and how it has
gotten just ridiculous
just ridiculous it needs to stop it
needs to be stopped
it's a disaster
1.7 trillion dollars in debt out there
and it's just nutty
so yeah check it out borrowed future it
came out back in october and it's still
going and blowing man steam steam rising
off of this thing so
uh good stuff as a matter of fact
my good friend mike rowe of dirty jobs
is in the documentary and he and another
friend of mine john rich had done a
funny christmas song about santa's got a
dirty job and it hit number one today
knocked adele off
so i was just emailing mike a minute ago
mike rowe and john congratulating them
on having the number one song santa's
got a dirty job
so check it out you don't want to miss
that either but yeah so mike's in there
and uh i was telling him he did a good
job he's a star but he already knew he
was a star so
um
you do need to watch borrowed future you
will thoroughly enjoy it sean is with us
sean is in philadelphia hi sean how are
you
good how are you dude better than i
deserve what's up um so i have a
question i recently just got uh married
and um we are trying to you know combine
our finances good um we paid off our
student
loans as far as um private student loans
good um the only
loan technically that we have is through
my
wife's father
um and i was wondering how you factor
that in into the debt strategy they
he said that um
he's not expecting in a certain period
of time
doesn't matter
put it right in there how much do you
owe him
so it's a lot it's 150 000 150 dollars
yes what's your degree
my
hey she's a doctor good so what's your
household income
um we are currently making 250
phenomenal um
but that is gonna go up when she
finishes her her education
so she's in residence and we're
expecting
yeah exactly she's in residence sheet
residency she has um until june she's
going to finish up
and we're hoping we're going to average
around 400.
wow
what other debt have you got other than
150 to her dad
so i have 40
000 on my months which i'm going to pay
off soon
um
and that's pretty much it
so make it so you owe 190 000 you make
250 today
uh how quickly do you pay 190 000 making
250 two years
hopefully two or three years two but we
also want to save um no you don't need
to save you need to get out of debt
you don't need to save for a down
payment you need to get out of debt
and that includes her dad
yeah so
190 000 so what do we need we need 100
000 a year for two years
and you're done yeah and you're free
forever let me just tell you what's
going to happen
when you eat thanksgiving dinner
with your father-in-law
and you don't owe him any money
it's gonna taste better
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this job hunting can be stressful
and time consuming but my friends at
ziprecruiter have made the whole job
search way easier ziprecruiter is rated
the number one job site in the us by g2
and it's free so how does it work first
go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show jeff is
with us in phoenix arizona jeff it says
on my screen you're dead free man way to
go
thanks dave i appreciate it thank you so
good to be on the show thank you honored
to have you how much you pay off
oh i paid off 140 000
very cool how long did that take
it took me about 34 months good for you
and your range of income during that
time
uh right around 95 up to about 100.
that's good for you what do you do for a
living
i'm a pa physician assistant ah okay
cool just talking to one of those and so
140 000 of what kind of debt i'm
guessing some student loans there
yeah so the bulk of it about 120 000 was
for the student loans and then about 20
000 there was some medical i had
reconstructive jaw surgery actually so
that was the other portion wow okay how
long you been out of school
uh just just past three years okay and
so
basically your first order of business
when you got out of school was attack
this debt then
oh yeah i mean i was i was ready to hit
the ground running you know it's
i got super fired up before graduation
and then i was ready on day one i wanted
to i wanted to go full on with the plan
so i did okay what made you want to do
this and know how to do it and how did
you get connected to us
yeah so my parents they were super early
like vhs style financial piece
university people um and then i you know
i didn't know too much uh about you and
then in high school actually i worked at
a christian bookstore and i think my
formal introduction to you was there was
a board game i think it was called act
your wage yeah and and we sold it in our
bookstore i think we used to play during
our breaks um we bought a copy and
and so i was like oh this guy and then i
listened off and on through the years
and then once i you know and then uh
when i was in school seeing those loans
go up i just you know it's that
constricting feeling you know sets in
and so i was like i got to get i got to
do the full day of plan i can't you know
i can't be davish yeah wow
so you uh mom and dad were in the
financial piece with the vhs tapes and
that makes you a financial piece baby
and then you get
act your wage in the bookstore my
goodness i don't know if i've ever had a
debt free caller that blamed it on the
board game
that's pretty yeah i don't know if you
played that you and sharon and the kids
you know on your game nights i always
wondered that but yeah we might have
once to make sure the thing worked but
um yeah it was uh
so we sold those things for years good
for you man that's so neat
so you just plowed him man you've been
beans and rice rice and beans you've
been cause there's not a lot of room in
this budget here to knock this amount of
data out in 34 months
no no i had i had a small amount like
maybe like 8 000 saved up in my checking
account uh that you know i had saved up
as much as i could before pa school and
so i was able to put you know small
amount of money on it afterwards and
then after that it was just it was super
tight i mean absolutely no vacations
um i didn't eat out except i mean i went
over to mom and dad's you know
restaurant that's that's a really cost
effective way to to technically eat out
well and they're cheering you on all the
way i'm sure
yeah yeah they've been they're here with
me actually they've been uh they've
certainly been my biggest cheerleaders
for that's for sure that's phenomenal
okay now that you did it you paid off
140 000 in 34 months
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is because you are
now a professional
yeah i mean there's so many keys dave
and obviously everybody talks about
staying focused and budgeting i think uh
to use kind of a medical analogy it's
you know i think you have to become
you know severely allergic to excuses
because
uh you know especially i think a lot of
people as you you get you know midway
through the baby steps or the you know
baby step two the the snowball you
really hit the mud and you hit the wall
and
you can get you know pretty fatigued and
i think that's when you start to a lot
of people derail because they start
going after the excuses for i'm gonna
finance a car i'm gonna finance this i'm
gonna and then
sooner you're off the wagon you're back
to step one so i think if you can
just you know anticipate that you're
gonna have that temptation that it's
gonna
increase as you're going along the
snowball you can get out in front of it
um and dig deep and it helps when you
have people to cheer you on or if you're
you know if you guys if you're doing it
with a spouse i'm not but you know if
you've got people to cheer you on that
helps you get through that yeah the
encouragement and the accountability you
don't want to look at them and say i
failed either right
yeah absolutely i mean you know
certainly when you've kind of set out
for this and i've had i've been so
blessed i mean god's blessed me
absolutely and then i've just been so
blessed with family that's cheered me on
from day one and so i certainly i wanted
to follow through and um you know i you
know committed to do this for myself my
family and i want to be about my word on
that yeah well done sir i'm proud of you
how does it feel to be free
oh it feels great when i you know it was
it was interesting you know dave when i
made the last payment we actually had a
family tragedy a week before then uh
lost a close relative and so
actually making the final payment it
took a long time
for that reason you know for it to
actually set in
but when it finally did set in it felt
like it took a couple months it was just
it just felt amazing to have finally
um to have finally been there it's just
incredible yeah you sit down with your
check and it doesn't have to go back out
to somebody else
exactly you have a moment
yeah i had the muscle memory i wanted to
log back on the known that and make
another student loan payment but
uh it just kept saying zero so yeah you
gave sally may her official official
eviction notice
oh i did she's out she's gone kick the
old woman into the street i like it well
done man exactly well done good for you
good for you thank you well jeff we've
got a copy of the baby steps
millionaires book that comes out in
january we're going to send you an early
release copy
because we fully expect you to be a baby
steps millionaire that's the next
chapter in your story uh first chapter
get out of debt second chapter be
wealthy third chapter be outrageously
generous so just keep it up man and you
picked out a wonderful career field to
get into and you've been very diligent
to uh to live your life well as a
grown-up adult adults devise a plan and
follow it children do what feels good
and we got a copy of total money
makeover for you uh to give to someone
else maybe you can inspire them the way
they'll act your wage game inspired you
years ago who knew who knew maybe i may
give them a board game too there you go
i like it that's fun all right jeff from
phoenix arizona 140 000 paid off in 34
months making 95 to 100 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three
two
one i'm dead free
[Applause]
love it
well that is exactly how it's done
ladies and gentlemen
that's the thing
so here's the deal
people do not get out of debt
because of their incomes
people do not get out of debt
because of mathematics
personal finance is 80 behavior
it's only 20 head knowledge the formulas
here a sixth grader can grasp
live on less than you make you are not
in congress
live on less than you make when you take
in more than you put out you have margin
you have spread to be generous and to
reduce and get rid of debt
but you have to quit spending so much
you have to quit buying things
with money that you don't have to
impress people you don't really like
you have to quit living a life
that is bigger than your income you need
to do what that board game said act your
wage
you need to live within your dadgum
income that's being a grown-up
you're not entitled to squat
well i feel like i'm do you're not do
anything
unless you save up and pay for it in
cash that's the only way when you earn
it that's when we know it's right that
you should buy it until then you
shouldn't be buying it
and even then you might not should be
buying it
dave ramsey wants me to work on minimum
wage and live and have no life now dave
ramsey wants you to be wealthy duper
and i'm going to show you how to be
wealthy but it requires paying a price
no one wins at anything without paying a
price to win
you weren't struck by lightning and made
god
you're just you
the principles of gravity and of getting
out of debt
apply to you they're called the truth
and when you decide the person in my
mirror has got to behave only then will
you begin to begin to get out of debt so
that you can build wealth
but if you want to be a millionaire i
can show you how
a hundred times out of 100 it works
i can show you exactly how
but it's a hard journey because it
requires dealing with that guy or gal in
your mirror
then they got issues just like my mirror
does
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
diego is with us in
phoenix arizona hi diego welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dave how you doing thank you for
taking my call sure what's up first time
caller first time listener honestly i
just started listening to you so it's
probably about
sunday oh wow okay i'm honored how can i
help
um
i'm in about 100 000 in debt
and
i have a i have i purchased a home about
in 2016
and i purchased it with my
brother-in-law and him and his wife
lived with me my wife and my daughter
and i don't know it's just been getting
too much for me already that i just want
to do my own thing with my family
and
just leave us on our own already
but
part of that hundred thousand dollars
i've been dead is to him
uh he's been helping us a lot
um he's he has this he has his job his
owner of his own company he makes about
over a hundred a year over a hundred
thousand a year
i i just started truck driving
and i'm barely making uh i just started
making 50 000 a year 51 000 a year about
two months ago
before that i was a phlebotomist and
just making
30 000 a year
and i don't know what would you
recommend having us just sell the house
and give him his part of
whatever we profited of it and then
whatever i've profited just pay him off
and pay all my debt off and
start fresh with my family and try and
try to
get into another house or or what would
you recommend me doing
well if you did all that you won't get
in another house you got to get out of
debt first and you'd be and so you'd be
in a rental
um so the
home you're living in that you own with
him
uh is there a mortgage on it
yes there's a mortgage uh are you on the
board
yes
um i was the one that got the loan
me and my wife my wife doesn't work so
i'm gonna i'm doing the one that has
income at home yeah for us okay how much
do you owe your brother-in-law
i owe him about
almost 15 000
okay what's the other 85 000 that you
have in debt
about 40
40 um 40 at school from because i was
going like i said i'm a phlebotomist but
i was going to school to be a laboratory
tech
and i stopped going just for different
reasons and i became a phlebotomist
and i never went back to school
so i just pretty much have a semester
left before okay so you got 40k in
student loans 15 to your brother-in-law
what's the rest of it
and then um about 10 000 in credit cards
and then 35 000 or so in a in a vehicle
okay
on a single car you owe thirty five
thousand dollars
yeah it's a brand new car mo does your
wife work outside the home
no she's just a stay-at-home mom okay
well when you make 51 dollars a year a
thirty five thousand dollar car loan is
what's called insanity
yeah yeah you gotta sell this car
okay it's ridiculous it's killing you
you got a 700 car payment don't you
600 yeah almost like i've done this
before
yeah and so um
man oh man yeah you're no wonder you're
you're drowning here so what is the
house that you're living in what's the
house you're living in worth
well i've just looked it up on google
and on zillow and stuff like that and
it's showing about 300 and
it was like 370 000 already and we only
owe 175
okay so there's about 100 equity and
there's about 100 equity in there and
when you're selling your car you could
be debt free and have a little money in
your pocket living in an apartment
or a rental house
yes making 51 000 a year and he you'd be
debt-free
you would pay him back and you'd be rid
of the vehicle
yeah yeah and and that's just for the
next three months by march i should be
because like i said i just started truck
driving and the company i'm at and i'm
like a junior driver so within three to
four months i'm gonna be making sixty
two thousand yeah still doesn't work for
a thirty five thousand dollar car loan
yep that's still a car is out of control
so it's gone it's got to go now so uh
when you guys bought the house together
did you have an agreement
on at what point this would end
no
honestly
and you thought you thought you would
live with him until you're 80.
not me honestly um my my brother-in-law
his wife is my wife's older sister yeah
and you thought you were here
you didn't have an end to date to this
or a way of getting out of this deal you
guys just signed up and thought you were
gonna live there forever
until for now so i don't know who knows
when yeah i understand well i know when
next week
so yeah you guys need to sell it
sell it yeah so that you can get out of
debt
and so that you can pay him back and so
your family can be on your own and
renting you're broke yeah because that's
me it's me my wife's biggest
arguments all the time that there's no
money no matter how much we do we're
still always in bed and more and more
and more and like exactly
and that's what that's due to two things
that's due to two things you have you
have a house loan that you can't afford
in a car loan that you can't afford and
you've had some job problems but now you
got the job thing straightened out
yep okay so if we get the income going
and we got the outgo the spending going
down because we get rid of this house
deal and we get rid of this car suddenly
you're going to have a great life can
you imagine what would it be like to
have no payments in the world and be
renting
yeah that can be yours
and sell the car sell the house
okay let me see my next question which
is renting my i like i said we want to
do stuff on our own
my parents own a little ranch they have
a guest house in the back like a town
private house is not connected to the
main house or nothing it's a one bedroom
one bath small living room how many kids
have you got what would you
i just have a little four-year-old
daughter she's gonna be foreign decided
i don't think this is probably gonna
work because i don't think your wife's
gonna be real thrilled with this
yes she's not that's [ __ ] yeah i
think you know
if you have no doubt
listen listen listen if you have no debt
no car payment
no house payment
and you rent something conservatively
you guys can spend the next two years
getting on your feet and saving up a
down payment and buying a home
you can but you're gonna have to clean
up the dead gum mess to get started
you're underwater right now you've got a
car that's a mess you got a house that's
a mess you got a living situation that's
untenable
and so you're exactly right i mean you
know what to do you just wanted me to
tell you
sell the car sell the house pay off your
brother-in-law pay off your student loan
pay off your credit cards cut them up
never have another car payment again
never have another credit card again
rent something inexpensive get yourself
on a budget and turn things around
you can do all of this and i can show
you how i'll show you how to do every
bit of it
so um hang on i'll have laura send you a
copy of the book the total money
makeover and show you and your wife
exactly what to do
and if you like that and really want to
get into it you can get into financial
peace university but for right now i'll
send you that book and get you started
elizabeth is with us in lincoln nebraska
hi elizabeth how are you
hi i'm doing well thanks for taking my
call dave sure i'm a little short on
time how can i help right quick
okay well um the short answer or the
short part of the story is my parents um
have
no annual income and
they are not willing to go and get
other forms of employment and so
my husband and i are concerned that
we'll end up paying for their retirement
and for
my younger sister who's a teenager and
has down syndrome and will likely be
dependent for the rest of her life
so
they'll go they're going to go get jobs
when they get hungry
well
that's
what i would assume but for the past 10
years they've been living off of
government aid and loans from family
members okay so from you as long as
those people
um i've loaned them ten thousand dollars
and i haven't seen a penny of that come
back are you through doing that
no
are you through loaning them money
i'm through loaning them money good good
that's an excellent start
you can't make mom and dad behave hon
i'd like to but they their locus of
control is theirs they get to control
this you can't even make them behave on
behalf of your
sister who's uh you know facing
disability and um gosh i wish you could
i wish we could make them behave but and
all you can do is go become wealthy and
then should you choose
as an act of generosity or grace to
participate somehow in their future
that's going to be completely up to you
you're under no obligation to do that
though none whatsoever
and they need to know that
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host thank
you for joining us america we're glad
you're here open phones at eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five
five two two five
brian is with us in atlanta georgia to
start off this hour hey brian how are
you
doing how about you dave better than i
deserve what's up
perfect
um
okay so
just a short background i i've come from
a
poor family
poor mindset
financially and everything
and as i've gotten older i have
you know i didn't follow on those
footsteps
i mean i'm debt free
married
and
you know i
like to maintain healthy boundaries and
i'm a small business owner
and
the
i
my income has risen drastically over
you know the past few years
congratulations
yeah
uh
um
well right now we're about around 25 000
a month good for you man well done
yeah
so um
my family on the other hand you know
they
still do their thing and my wife her her
family's not
you know they're
they they do well so they're not like
this either so we don't get it from both
sides but i guess what i'm asking is uh
what is the
when you're starting to comment like i'm
not i feel weird just even saying that
just because
pal is raised
um and i want to make sure that we are
the
i don't mind helping my family but
whenever they smell like
i don't know
uh like i just bought a house almost in
cash like we're gonna pay it off in like
a year
um
but
they they have controversy they have
emergencies and
you know like they make decisions that
cause them to be where they're at
and i don't like to enable them
and so they like to
put me on guilt trips and things like
that and
you know especially since i've been
married you know if money's involved
you know i tell them that well my wife
has to be involved in these
conversations and
you're gonna ask me for money and
and then
i don't really care for that because
they don't practice boundaries
so okay so who's asking who's asked you
for money
um i mean my mother does on a very
regular basis and she is she singles
she's single um she's on disability but
she's allowed to work 20 hours a week
and that's where i encourage her what i
encourage her to do
and how much money have you given her
well dave i haven't given her money in
several years when i was younger in my
teens and early 20s i'm 34 now
i used to give her money all the time
so when you stopped giving her money it
was how long ago
about 2015. okay so it's been it's been
six years since you gave her any money
and she still asks right
she'll still ask oh my my mother's very
relentless with things and then recently
my brother has come into some
hard times and he'll ask and you know i
we've given him small amounts but you
know again discuss with my wife because
that's a small amount
um
like
four hundred dollars a thousand dollars
okay and so what what prompted this call
who asked you recently
um well my mom is trying to move
back to this area where i'm from and
she's
done everything but
like
a total fit over the fact that i won't
like
pay for her move and get her here
you know you know what i mean just just
make it happen for her and the thing is
i i've given her money in the past
and she's you know i've put her in a
house before and she literally burnt it
to the ground
um you know
years ago and so like i
i think she's healthier now in terms of
like she her
addictions are no longer
in control of her life
but i definitely don't want to
um okay let's let's stop a minute all
right what i'm gonna do when we hang up
i'm gonna send you a copy of my friend
dr henry cloud's book boundaries
it is the absolute bible on this issue
um it is the best book and he sold 10
million copies and i love my copy it has
helped me
with so many things over the last 20
years and so you want to read that book
because you're going to read the first
chapter and just be laughing out loud
and go how did this guy know because
he's going to like read your mail okay
so what this teaches you is this
that you you are not under a moral
obligation to give
anyone
money
except your own spouse
and children who are minors that live in
your home
you're supposed to take care of them
but your brother and your mother you are
not under a moral obligation
just because you have the same blood
that they have
okay yeah period
okay and no matter how big a fifth they
throw
or no matter what so now once we've
removed that you're not under obligation
then you say okay under what
circumstances would i want to be
generous
right
and there's only one circumstance that
you want to be generous and that is
where you're actually helping someone
move
through their life
and get traction
helping someone is not
assisting them in continuing their
stupidity
okay so buying a drunk a drink
is enabling it's not helping now the
drunk may throw a fit and say you won't
buy me my alcohol
and if you were a good son you'd buy me
my alcohol
right
and they may say all of that but that
doesn't make any of that true agreed
agree just because they say it doesn't
make it true
and so the definition of help
if you're not an enabler
means the person
moves on to the next stage of their
personal growth and their life is better
as a result of you having assisted
and so
in our case if it were sharon and i in
this kind of a situation although we've
not been in this exact situation
but the way for instance with ramsey
family foundation if we're helping a
family or an individual
on an ongoing basis now one time we
might buy somebody a truckload of
groceries and fill up their cabinets
okay just so they're not hungry that's
that's one that's a one-off though but
if i'm gonna assist mom in moving and
pay her rent for four months
she's going to produce some fruit in her
life that indicates that she's growing
into a sustainable life meaning she's
going to get a job and keep it she's
going to be on a budget and keep it
she's going to be in financial peace
university and i'm going to pay for it
and you're going to get better mom
you're going to get better and better
and better and better but i'm not going
to pay for you to get worse and worse or
stay the same
because that's not helping
that's enabling
and real love
requires that the person have a better
life as a result of being intersected
with you
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying thousand dollars about two
years after that i got a remote job that
pays me a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars all thanks to what i learned at
bethel tech you could be next get
started today at betheltech.net
and get 1000 to twenty five hundred
dollars off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
um
[Music]
well the christmas countdown is on at
ramsey solutions we've been in a
christmas frame of mind for many weeks
we're having a great time handing out
free cash
as part of our christmas cash giveaway
because if you didn't know giving is the
most fun you'll ever have with money
every year we celebrate christmas with
our ramsey show listeners with an
awesome tradition our ramsey christmas
cash giveaway
this year we're giving away around 500
every week we've already started that
and a grand prize of five thousand bucks
and you can enter to win every day to
increase your chances of winning no
purchase necessary ramsey solutions dot
com slash giveaway
and look we know you're planning to do a
lot of giving and that's why our team is
extending
our biggest cyber monday sale ever
where you can get up to 79 off it's the
perfect time
a perfect price to get kids gifts like
the adventure pack our popular starter
envelope system ken coleman's career
assessment these are the lowest prices
of the year
get gifts your family and friends and
maybe yourself
and you can save up to around 80 percent
off it's pretty cool
shop our biggest cyber monday sale yet
online store
ramseysolutions.com heather's in
chattanooga hi heather welcome to the
ramsay show
hi
hey what's up um hi
um a lot actually
i have a couple questions
um
just trying to make it as quick as i can
my first i'm a little bit nervous
because the first time i ever called in
we've never lost a patient you'll be
okay
okay
um well my
the reason i'm calling is is my husband
and i
um
are in the process of
or habit in the process of building a
custom home
and
we
hired a really bad contractor and the
reason being is because our contractor
wants us to fire him
when our house is about 90 complete
and
it's been two years and eight months and
we still have not closed on this house
and when he gave us the
price uh well we signed a contract
and on the contract um the price he gave
us to build it was it's around a 3100
square foot home
and the price they gave us was uh for
415 000 to build it
and now we're looking at 625 000.
i'm sorry i thought you had do you have
a contract at 415
yes
and the start date was
august on the contract it says august of
2019 and it was supposed to be completed
in april of 2020 and here we are and we
still have not closed
and we should have do you own the do you
have you giving this guy money
no
okay and um in the contract it stated
that he do you own the lot that he gets
yes we do we paid cash we paid roughly
around 32 000
for the lot
so yes we did pay for the lot
and in the contract that states that he
would get 60 000 and we have not paid
him a penny
on that
but the problem we're having is we're
paying we've been paying a construction
loan
from the beginning obviously
and right now we're paying
roughly around
two thousand eight dollars two thousand
eight hundred dollars a month
on top of having to pay rent for a
townhouse that we've lived in um so what
have you done in the past ten months
about this
because this has been going on a long
time
right we contacted an attorney and
he basically told us
that
we need to try to close we're kind of
too far into it we need to close
and we can't close because
the fact that we we have no more money
uh we can't continue paying this
construction loan and the reason why
we're
you know we found out through history
you have a construction loan
yes did you give him money
out of the construction loan no
we have we have a
a lender
yeah and where did the money go from the
construction loan
we pay a monthly payment towards our
concerns every month but you don't is
the loan just that loans not been
dispersed at all
you shouldn't be paying interest on a
construction loan unless the money's
been paid out to someone have you been
paying bills on this house
yes so that what we do is is we
what we what he does is he'll give us an
invoice yeah and uh then we pay okay so
you're doing a cost plus you're doing a
cost plus arrangement with him where
you're paying him a fee for his building
services and you pay all the expenses of
the actual materials and labor
yes yes and you paid for all of that up
to now
yes okay and why have how why have you
not just run him off and closed it then
um well
you already own the house you own the
lot and you're already in debt up to
your eyeballs why not just turn it into
a mortgage and call it a day
we have that we can't close on the house
though we went to the um because
the problem is is because
we still have electrical the electrical
scene still needs to be finished the
plumbing and all that we have that's why
we're not able to close on the house
because he wants to try to fire us
i'm sorry he wants us to fire him
because he doesn't want to come in and
finish the work
and so now
have you paid for work that has not been
done
um have we paid for work that has not
been done yeah i mean how do you owe
more ounce construction if the plumbing
has not been done why did you pay
plumbing that hasn't been done
we paid the first portion of the
plumbing
okay what's the balance on the
construction loan today
um
right now it's 100 and uh roughly around
118 000 okay on a house that you were
supposed to get for four hundred
thousand
so are you are you 50 are you 50
complete
190 complete wow but we've well we run
into problems where for example he
the people that he's hired to come in
his so-called crew that he just gets
wherever
um
he doesn't come in and check their work
and so we've had issues where
um
our floor has buckled
because there was water damage under our
house um due to him not waterproofing
around the perimeter of our home and so
we had to stop and do that and so
trying to
fire him what would it take to finish
this deal
well that's my question with you is um
how much money will it take to get the
house done
100 and around 100 a little over a
hundred thousand dollars oh so you're
not even half done
you're not 90 done
right
well no no because well that's well the
the bank came out to see and they're
saying that we're 90 complete
that's what they're saying well yeah but
but you're not you're not percent
complete if you need a hundred thousand
so somebody's wrong
well the hundred thousand is
is because they have to do the rough-ins
i guess is that with it the rough ends
where they come in and they finish out
the electrical and that's the thing is
we're not able
to finish out
um but you haven't drawn the entire you
haven't drawn that half of your
construction loan
you should have more to draw on this
construction loan right
what a draw from the construction so the
total construction loan should have been
250 300 000 on this deal
and it's only 150 so far
that you've drawn against it because
that's what your balance is right
well when we we met with the bank
towards uh
the middle of it when we found out he
um
basically
underbid everything when it comes to
electrical and plumbing
so when they came out to actually do the
work it was more than what he better for
like for example with the brick and the
block but you only owe 150 000 on the
construction loan you told me this was
going to be a 400 000 house and now it's
gone to 600 000.
so that means that this house should
have been built for 300 and some change
which means you should have had a
construction loan approved for up to 300
to 350 and you've only drawn 150 you
should be able to draw the risk the rest
of the construction loan and finish the
house with a different builder
right but we were too far into that
because he had already uh
he'd already went in it's hard to
explain yeah i'm sorry i'm not i'm not
tracking with you i think you've got
some of your uh information sideways or
maybe i'm just not understanding i wish
i could be more help hunt but it sounds
like you're obviously gonna have to get
another builder you've got the debt
you've got the real estate you've got to
find a way to finish this project and
get rid of him yesterday
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage derek and lauren are
with us hey guys how are you good how
are you welcome where do you guys live
in valdez north carolina which is near
morgan morganton north carolina perfect
good to have you guys yes sir welcome to
nashville and here to do a debt free
scream how much have you paid off
92 thousand dollars in four very long
years
yeah okay works for me and what was your
range of income during those four very
long years probably about 50 to 60
somewhere around there yeah i'm a
teacher and she was a teacher assistant
at one time and then
uh changed jobs to working from home
okay cool cool what kind of debt was the
92 000
it was half student loans and half
credit cards okay about split down the
middle just right there 45 46 000 bucks
each okay cool
so uh why were the four years long what
happened gosh
i don't know just kids moves grind out
yeah yeah and you know on a teacher's
salary you're not bringing in a ton of
income and
um it was just you just had to put your
head down and and persevere i think that
was the toughest part of yeah just
getting started and finishing it yeah
what got you started
her uh actually well we i originally in
2004 we got married and i bought the
original total money makeover book from
you and
uh we tried it and didn't follow through
and then
probably about four or five years ago
um she was like hey we need to get into
financial peace she listened to your
show every day
working from home so that helped yeah
and i was like that's what i wanted
that's what i want for christmas and so
he took it like the next february and he
like i dragged him until about the
second class and he's like all right
this is awesome
because i'm the spender she's the savers
and i didn't realize that at times but
financial piece helped to bring that out
so okay totally and get it under control
absolutely because we have a common goal
that's bigger than whatever i want to
buy today yes sir yeah way to go guys
all right thank you so the original
total money makeover book and then uh
the podcast and then financial peace
university as a christmas present yes
you're going four years ago that is
correct very good correct very good good
for you guys well done
okay so you're scratching and clawing
and fighting your way through
uh how many kids you got we have two
they're here with us today okay good
they're gonna do the screen with us did
they survive i think they did apparently
they're healthy yeah and it was funny
you know the kids were home doing
virtual school and i would listen to the
podcast and the debt-free screams was
definitely what kind of kept me going
and encouraging and our son he'd be like
oh that was lame and he would rate the
other people's debt-free screens
so he's like mommy when we go we need to
like we need to bring it we got to have
a 10.
10. on a scale of 1 to 10 yeah that's
right that's right good good we'll we'll
rate you when you're done
good job you guys well this is a long
slog congratulations how do you stay
with it for four years
well
really i think kind of the motivation
was just the goal of checking things off
list and paying one credit card off and
then paying one debt off and
we had like a little debt thermometer on
the fridge and we you know eat dinners
you saw it every day but
you know that i think that helped us
just to stay focused on it and after so
long it just became a habit like it was
honestly towards the end fun to do bills
because it didn't take an hour and a
half it only took half an hour and
you're just seeing yes like things that
got marked off like it kind of became a
game towards the end yeah it was
enjoyable that's cool yeah that's cool
very cool well you guys gutted it out
that's a long run
well done very well done what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is
i get started but you also do it you
also have to have the accountability
like she was my accountability partner
like if i'm the spender and she's the
saver
uh doing the envelopes really helped and
instead of as a restriction it was you
know your your ultimate goal is to get
out of debt and that was the kind of the
the motivation but um you know i coach
football too so we teach kids to be
disciplined and i wasn't very
disciplined so i had to have my coach
keep me in line and keep me accountable
and that's that i think helped motivate
me to stick with it but
also to
to do right for her you know this
partnership and uh making sure that i'm
supporting her so it was a teamwork
thing yeah yeah that's a big deal very
well done when so when you're going to
financial peace university she drags you
in there and wanted for a christmas
present took two classes what happened
inside your mind do you think derek
in that second class or around that
second class that you went
okay wait a minute we're doing this
i mean you flipped right well i think
just
you know you as a coach you tell the
kids leave a legacy in it i don't want
to leave a legacy of debt and us
struggling and us constantly
uh being restricted and not being able
to the freedom i guess you would say in
part with that but uh but what happened
in that class what did you see that said
i can do this or we got to do this or
what was it i remember part of it you
know one of the i think it's at the end
of the first class everyone totals up
their total debt and kind of sends it in
and there were six other families but we
were over half the debt of the total
debt yeah like oh my word it was
embarrassing it was awful sorry
i guess
out of embarrassment i was like oh man
we can't do this anymore that's bad so
yeah we're the whole problem that's
right
yeah so i guess the embarrassment factor
okay that'll turn in it did that'll move
your butt i got it
very cool all right well let's bring the
kiddos in tell me their names and ages
all right we have landon he is 12.
and our daughter emery and she's 14. all
right very cool good good good well
we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you an early release
copy it comes out in january but i'll
give you one today thank you because
it's definitely the next chapter in your
story to go on and become baby steps
millionaires you're on your way you get
the hard part out of the way yes sir
this is the hard part the wealth
building is easy from here and we'll
give you a copy of the total money
makeover as well you can give it away
pay it forward get somebody moving this
christmas and this will be the year that
they get their journey we'll just
started because of you guys so well done
so proud of y'all heroes thank you thank
you well done what was the uh who were
your biggest cheerleaders outside of
your family
like our class yeah pu class
just having the in person accountability
and people to answer too and we had a
few people in class that had been
through it already the kids were gone
and now it's like how do they do the
investing side so
and telling our parents to you know just
encouraging us along the way and they
they helped us out too
um so that always helps have family
support oh yeah cook a meal if nothing
else you know i mean oh my gosh it's
wonderful yeah sunday afternoon after
church go to mom's house there you go
i'm in i think i'm going with you next
time i bet that's some good cooking
right there yes sir all right good stuff
good stuff all right from morganton
north carolina derrick and lauren and
the kids emery and landon 92 thousand
dollars paid off in four years making 50
to sixty thousand count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
and one two three
[Applause]
i think landon gets a 10. i think that
was a 10 landing good job man well done
oh that's so fun
so here's what happens
i mean how many of you can think back
when you were 12 or 14 years old
i can see things pretty clearly i'm 61.
i can see things pretty clearly in 14
year old dave
stuff that happened 12 year old dave i
remember that stuff
and they'll remember this they made a
trip
from north carolina to tennessee
to celebrate
the fact that the family had engaged in
a four year
long
journey of transformation
now let me just tell you getting out of
ninety two thousand dollars worth of
debt a mathematically will change your
family tree
but what emory and landon have
experienced during that time and then
they experienced this milestone this
celebration this trip to nashville i
remember they'll be telling their
grandkids i remember back in august 22
our 21 christmas was coming on and we
drove to tennessee and did our debt free
scream and they'll be 92 years old
telling their grandkids this
because then they'll be millionaires 10
millionaires
telling their kids about the time that
their daddy and mama change their life
and change their family tree see that's
the definition of a hero
people that take control of their own
lives they're not arrogant they're not
entitled
they're not waiting on someone in
washington to fix their life
they're not whining
they just put their head down did the
freaking work
to get their lives back
from a dad gum credit card companies
from dadgum sally may
gotta pay a price to win mom and bo
boys and girls that's how it works
that's how it works these people right
here they're heroes
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
our scripture today isaiah 40 and 8 the
grass withers the flower fades but the
word of our god stands forever
president john f kennedy said i would
rather be accused of breaking precedence
than breaking promises
andrew is with us andrew is in
washington uh north wilmington north
carolina i'm sorry hi andrew how are you
i'm great how are you doing better than
i deserve what's up
you said you've never lost a patient um
i'm a pretty good runner and literally
is about to jump out of my chest so i
might be the first one to draw
love it oh my gosh
it is an honor a privilege and yeah i'm
humbled to be able to talk to you i have
you too sir for you for years
and um you are a humongous inspiration
to me and my family thank you so much
for all that you do for so many people
thank you sir i'm very honored how can i
help today
well uh dave i have a question um i mean
my wife at just very brief we are i'm 51
she's 47. uh we are uh have a net worth
of between 1.4
and 1.5 million dollars we don't have
any debts way to go um
yes sir and uh we uh
i we have one child that's in high
school in the ninth grade we have one
child that's in sixth grade we've got
two 529s uh for about eighty five
thousand a piece in them uh that's part
of the 1.41.5
wonderful and uh my wife uh makes uh 75
i make about one in five
and i have a dream core out there and
it may not be today but in the next year
or two
it's a um acura tlx type s
it's about fifty five thousand dollars i
just came out with it uh in july
and i've always thought you know
that's a lot of money um
but we have been very blessed and have
been financially responsible
if i went out there tomorrow and bought
that car would that be a mistake no i
had the money that's no
it would not be a mistake
it would be why you've done everything
you've done to get to this point
one of the research is not the only why
i mean a car is not your why but i mean
it's
um
so here's here's the rules that i look
at okay and you probably you said you've
been listening a long time you probably
heard me say these things but we'll just
reiterate them for the rest of the
audience
we tell folks not to buy a brand new
vehicle unless you've got a net worth of
a million dollars simply because
brand new cars go down in value very
rapidly and in order to absorb the loss
of money
you need to have a lot of money
that's what it comes down to and so
for someone that has a million and a
half dollars to lose
fifty thousand dollars
is not back breaking
for someone that has fifty thousand
dollars to lose fifty thousand dollars
is back breaking
and the number of people that have a
negative net worth that go buy a brand
new fifty five thousand dollar car on
car payments you and i both know them
all the time and then they wonder why
they're broke
because they've got you know they've got
more than their entire net worth tied up
in things that are going down in value
in your case
number one you've got the ability to
absorb the loss in value that this car
all cars
will have so you can afford a new car
you can afford that um and it's not dumb
it's not out of control
um yes now if you were gonna buy a half
million dollar car i would question you
on it
because that would be a third i mean
then a third of your net worth tied up
in something that's going down in value
and half a million cars go down in value
too
so and they're out there they're around
you can find them um so but that that's
the thing the second thing i look at in
addition to have you built a you know
amassed over a million dollars in order
to buy a brand new car is anything i'm
purchasing and i always coach
high net worth people on this and sharon
and i use the same rule
is to look at ratios
and the ratio is okay
a 50 000
car
for you
is about three percent
of your net worth
and so it's like someone that has a
hundred thousand dollar net worth buying
a three thousand dollar car
same ratio
right it's not that doesn't sound unwise
to me
if you have a hundred thousand dollars
and you spent three thousand on a car
that would not be unwise
right right and if you did it again in
six more months it wouldn't be unwise
because
because the ratio tells us that it's an
unimportant
amount of money it doesn't change your
life you could put 55 000
in the fire pit in your backyard gather
up some lawn chairs and burn it and it
wouldn't change your life other than
you'd have an emotional heart attack but
um but i mean the the mathematics are
your life would not not even change one
ounce
right well how do i i guess the big
thing is too and and i i love what you
say about
looking from the means to the left to
right dave i'm one of these people who
get hamburger in the store and get a
ground up and put it in packages just to
save it because you can get more to bulk
and my habits haven't changed my income
me and my wife again have been very very
blessed but i still look at the bottom
line of the meal price and i'm thinking
well you'll probably always do that i
mean those of us that came from nothing
that built wealth
we're always going to read the menu from
right to left we're going to start start
at the price and then look at the item
you got to have a lot of money a long
time to break yourself from that
but what you do want to do is you want
to practice the muscle
you practice the muscle of frugality and
of saving and investing
and i suspect you're generous you
probably built that muscle
and you also want to practice the muscle
of enjoying
the money
right and so uh you know occasionally
sharon and i just make ourselves do
something and say hey
this is not even
i mean i made this i made more than this
while we were sitting here eating this
meal and yet it was an extremely
expensive meal we're gonna practice the
art of enjoying
the meal i mean i saw more books on
amazon while i was sitting there that
paid more than paid for the meal right
while i was eating right so i'm okay you
know shut up dave stop your whining and
enjoy the meal you know you tight wide
and you just kind of have to train your
brain to do that and you can tell i've
kind of had that internal tape playing
like everybody else has right
but i have to have some way i can work
it through and go
this doesn't matter shut up and enjoy it
this is why we work so hard is to be
able to do this and not to waste money
and not to be uh uh irresponsible
but to actually go i can buy an a luxury
item a luxury experience
and it's why i work so stinking hard
and just like you and that's what you've
done i'm so proud of you very well done
sir my dad might i'll just say the
shares with you today you've been honest
my dad um he lived uh right at 48 years
of age uh he died 20 i'm 51
so he died back in 94. and
my dad was always a he always he could
go anywhere he was a farmer he worked
very hard for his money he worked full
time at a particular job besides that
my dad could always he always had money
in the back of his pocket and he always
when he wanted to get something he went
there and he bought it he had cash
and i i didn't know about dave ramsey
back then i i didn't know anything about
it but my dad with his principles
uh it just he was instilled dentist me
and my wife were by god's grace were
able to pay off our house it's like
eight eight and a half years
um but we
you know i i try every day to
you know as you said you know
give some away uh you know save some and
spend some and uh you're so right with
being balanced and uh
i don't know it's uh we mean wifes have
taken money we've uh
we've got about half a million that's
that we've converted into the roth ira
and that's a lot of that money is
already converted into the roth which is
going to grow from 51 however to however
long yeah and so just god has helped us
to open our ears and to listen and pay
attention to people like yourself well
you've just done a wonderful you've done
a wonderful job andrew very very well
done i'm so proud of you guys you're
classic baby steps millionaires i mean
you've done that started from nothing
and you just worked and saved and worked
and saved and worked and saved and
you've had a good life you've not uh
never gone on vacation you've not never
enjoyed anything but you've just been
very intentional and very careful and
the exercise exercising the enjoyment
muscle is one of the muscles we all must
learn to use
with money as we as we you know the
pendulum swings back the other way we're
not broke anymore
thank you for your call it's an honor to
talk to you sir i appreciate your time
thanks to james childs in the booth
laura filling in for kelly today i am
dave ramsey your host we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com
and register we would love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story
[Music]
you